Yeah, I definitely say it's been an important  few months.
For me, my life was always "go go" tennis wise...
...especially after, you know, the previous US Open that I won.
It definitely accelerated things and I've never had the chance to slow down...
...so the quarantine definitely gave me a chance to think a lot about things,...
...what I want to accomplish, what I want people to remember me by.
And, for me I came in to this tournament,...
...or these two tournaments, with that mindset.
I think it definitely helped me out.
Yeah, I think I definitely did that.
I feel a very good and recent example is the second set,...
...or the first set and the second set of the match that I played today.
I think I could've easily faded away but I really wanted to fight...
...and just compete and, I don't know, honestly...
...there wasn't really another thought in my mind.
I wasn't really thinking about winning,...
...I was thinking about competing and somehow I ended up with the trophy.
But, yeah I feel like I've definitely tried to mature.
I wasn't really sure the process that I was going to have to take...
...but I feel like you know, the lessons that I learned with life...
...definitely develop me as a person more.
Yeah, I mean definitely I feel like for me,...
...I learn more through experiences so I want to, you know,...
...everyone sort of think things they know...
...or I actually don't want to know how are they feeling...
...or how they felt during the process...
...but for me, I feel like sharing stories...
...and hearing, you know, people's experiences is very valuable.